[موسيقى]
الصيصان
الحلوين
[موسيقى]
مثل الماما يمشون مبتسمين
هي تطعمهم هي تسقيهم
حامدين نعمل مولى شاكرين
[موسيقى]
اصح
ي سلمى
مبتسمين مبتسمين هي تطعمهم هي تطعمهم هي
تسقيهم هي تسقيهم حاملين نعمل مولى شاكرين
هم صغار لكن شطار
لوصايا ماماهم دوما مستمعين
هم طائعون طائعون ومؤدب ومؤدب حين تنادي
ماما ياتوها في الحين
[موسيقى]
شيطان الحلوين الحلوين خلف الماما يمشون
مبتسمين
[موسيقى]
هي تطعمها هي تسقيهم هي تسقيهم حامدين
نعمل مولى شادي
[موسيقى]
يلعبون
ويمرحون
طول اليوم في لهون مستمتعين مع الاصحاب مع
الاصحاب او الالعاب او الالعاب يقضون احلى
اوقات ينفرحين
الصيصان الحلو
ين الماما يمشون مبتسمين
هي تطعمون هي تسقيهم
حامدين نعمل مولى شاكر